first of all what was he like so you had
a five-hour conversation and it was
quite in-depth it was a five-hour
conversation where he sketched out
really his plan for the kingdom he has
this obsession about moving the Saudi
economy away from oil and basing it
around something new and this there's
two trillion fund into which Aramco will
go is an amazing thing if you think
about it's enough to buy Google
Microsoft the the alphabet the whole lot
of them all that Warren Buffett all
those things could go into one thing and
they'd still have changed to spare and
in into that fund is going to go Ramco
they've already got SABIC inside it
industrial arm they can add land
property all these other things and it's
roughly twice as big as any other or
more than twice as big than any other
sovereign wealth fund his obsession
right to move it away from oil as
understandable given the volatility we
saw in the old price and the fact that
we have concerns that Saudi haven't done
the structural reforms needed yes and
that he's pushing on very hard as well
and he's already cut all the subsidies
and they're now moving on to other
things is it's a rather dramatic plan in
terms of the kind of the economic
transformation of the country Oh John
all of us were weaned on Daniel Yergin
the prize or Robert Lacey's books the
kingdom everybody read cover to cover as
their first window into the royalty we
all understand this is a generational
change did you get that tone in your
interview and if it is a generational
change where are they heading well I
think it is there is something of a
generational change his father is king
and you have Muhammad bin Nayef who is
the Crown Prince and he's deputy Crown
Prince but there is an element of a
group of mostly young reformers around
him who want to push very much step on
the accelerator in terms of change there
and it you know there will be some
people at some people know royal family
but certainly people from the religious
side who will be suspicious and worried
about this but I think there isn't that
there is an element whereby Saudi Arabia
has to change they were stuck in a
situation where they were running out
right I'm sure a really needed it I'm
sure you were briefed John by Riyadh
Hamad and John fryer and our teams on
the oil dynamics of the Middle East
what is the
level of desperation in Saudi Arabia
about the funding of those domestic
responsibilities and having enough in
the bank is they've had for generations
what's a level of sweat in Riyadh well
you look and see that universe most of
their revenues have come from oil and
the idea of setting this up as an
investment fund is that that will change
even technically because Aramco will go
into it it will no longer be coming
directly from oil they've become a bit
like very similar to you Tom an investor
sitting there living on several trillion
dollars and not and not moving means
that it's a it's going to change even
the way they think about it I think and
that I think is important and they're
also going to try and build up over the
next few years a whole variety of
different in a bit of different
investments and even if you look at
Saudi Aramco the aim there is very much
to go from just being a producer of the
oil it's by far the biggest producer of
oil in the world to becoming the world's
biggest refiner they've already got that
very clearly in their sights they refine
about five billion baht five billion
barrels a day at the moment they want to
push that up to eight million ten
million you want to be open to
petrochemicals and in the end their plan
for Aramco is to be a huge industrial
energy Kingdom with energy company so it
goes across the whole parameters I mean
this is a fairly dramatic change in the
industrial makeup of both the country
and and the and the oil market